[Music]
foreign
hello and welcome to I'd like to know my
name is CA Murray and this is one of our
favorite programs here at Secrets
unsealed and some TV because it gives us
an opportunity to answer your questions
to see what's on your mind and on your
heart and it gives us an opportunity to
do something that we like to do and that
study open and share the word of God I
am in the company of my colleague in
Ministry Pastor David Salazar he is
fairly new and we're trying to make him
welcome here at Secrets unsealed in 7 TV
we like him already he's a nice guy
student of the word have not met his
family yet but we're going to love them
also so David good to have you here man
thank you Pastor thank you for having me
here is a blessing for me and of course
uh for the ministry to be able to join
these wonderful work and I'm here to
hopefully like you said study the
scriptures and share with others about
the Lord and his love for us amen Pastor
David brings with him multiple ability
teeth he first is bilingual and it seems
as though everybody here is bilingual
except me
um you're getting there I'm sort of one
and a half
trying to do the best I can but he also
has building skills student of the word
uh we like this guy and we know that
he's going to be a blessing to the
ministry
the other reason we like this program
again as we said it gives us a chance to
answer your questions and see what's on
your mind on your heart should you like
to get in on the fun we encourage you to
do so by writing us at uh TV at some
tv.org that is TV at some
tv.org and we will get to your questions
now we've got to sort of warn you a
little bit because we've got a fairly
impressive stack of questions
so if you don't hear your question right
away by the grace of God we will get to
it but it may take us a little while for
a couple of reasons one of you don't
want to rush to the questions we like to
take our time with each question because
if you take the time to send it in we
want to take the time to answer it
thoroughly from the word of God if an
answer can be found in the word of God
we make you that promise
so we move not for Speed but for
accuracy and that's how we want to do it
so we'll get to them uh it may take us a
little while but we're going to get each
and every question we want to start out
today's program uh with the word of
prayer and Pastor David if you would
pray for us we'll launch out absolutely
let's pray Heavenly Father we are so
thankful Lord that we you can allow us
to learn you from your word and we are
humbly asking you right now that the
Holy Spirit may lead us into all truth
help us to understand and may your word
speak plainly to us and without any
biased ideas or opinions but may your
word shine in this moment we pray in
Jesus name amen amen and amen our first
question comes to us from Joseph he is
writing to us from Kenya I've had the
privilege of being in Kenya and
preaching in Kenya wonderful country
Adventist Church is doing quite well in
Kenya and God is blessing the work uh
here's the question the Bible is clear
that God said and his only son Jesus
Christ to die on the cross but then I
also read that it says cursed is the
person who should fulfill that prophecy
my question is why should Judas Iscariot
be condemned to perish for doing
something that was already known that it
would happen is it fair or is there some
information that I am missing this is uh
from Dr Fred from Kenya
well this is an interesting question
Pastor as you can see and thank you Fred
for sending the question I think that
the important aspect that he's
mentioning here in the first aspect is
that it is true Galatians 3 13 mentions
that Jesus was cursed by taking the role
of dying the cross for us and that is
true because as he took the sins upon
himself he became in essence cursed by
uh for being becoming sin for us you
know taking that penalty of sin so that
is important and that's really an
important point that Dr Fred is
mentioning or or stating there in his
question now the question he goes into
saying is why would Judas you're right
he uh you know will be condemned now
just so I can I suppose the the answer
would be that first of all Christ took
upon himself that sin and he is the one
that is taking that penalty of sin he
became curse for us including the sins
of everybody including the sins of Judas
including the sin of him uh you know
betraying the Lord now that does not
mean that Christ is
um taking away the penalty to those who
reject his loving grace and his Mercy in
other words even though Christ took upon
himself all his all the sins and and he
became a curse for us taking the penalty
taking the what we deserve the Sinners
deserve to have uh he does not or that
does not mean that those who reject
Christ and his righteousness and he's
forgiving Grace are going to be
blameless you know they're going to be
condemned so in that scenario you know
Christ is or by understanding that
aspect that principle
Judas like any other sinner who rejects
the Lord is going to be condemned yeah
it's not going to be a way for him to be
saved so even though he fulfilled
prophecy of scriptures that there wasn't
going to be you know his friend who who
will betrayed him is not necessarily uh
just because he fulfilled the prophecy
he's not in any way pardoned or excused
of that behavior that decision of
rejecting the Lord and of course between
Christ yeah well said well said uh David
a couple of things come to my mind yeah
one I I have a sermon that kind of
studies this as part of a series I call
it Judas the self-made man
Judas set himself up for this
um we find out from Spirit of Prophecy
his inordinate Love of Money really
poisoned his heart and and you know
there's a text uh Galatians 5 9 it says
a little 11 11 of the hola
saying that you're allowed to fester in
your life will take over your life
absolutely and and as such will shut out
the the Rays of God's love so Judas sort
of predestined himself now having said
that um uh Ellen White says this she
says Judas love money so much he was
willing to follow Christ but when it
came to matters of money he thought
Christ ought to listen to him you know
he thought Christ out of line up behind
him that's how unbalanced he became
because of the Love of Money all right
let me ask you this question and it's a
rhetorical whose sin is worse Judas
betraying him Peter denying him
yeah they're basically the same
precisely precisely they're both very
bad Sin so how does become how does
Peter become a lord of the church and
Judas not it's because Peter accepted
the Forgiveness that was available to
him Judas did not I take issue with one
line he says Judas Iscariot be condemned
to perish he was not condemned to perish
he could have gotten the same Grace the
same Mercy the same forgiveness that
Peter got but he didn't Avail himself of
that he felt bad he threw the money down
he went out and hanged himself but I
dare say Christ would have forgiven him
Christ nowhere said Judas you're
competing committing the unpardonable
sin yeah Judas I cannot forgive you
Judas I'm washing my hands if you've
never said that Judas gave up on Jesus
Jesus never gave up on Judas uh and and
that's what's important for us to know
absolutely that regardless of what is
happening in your life
you still have a friend in Christ Jesus
so Christ told him after the let's look
at the scenario they're at this Feast at
Simon's house right
Ellen White tells us that Christ never
Christ knew he says uh I've chosen all
of 12 of you and one of you is the devil
so he knew he was dealing with but he
never called Judas out
uh until that feast
Judah said well why is this why is this
um
this money being wasted we could have
sold it for 300 poor for the first time
Christ said why are you bothering her
leave her alone uh that's Mark chapter
14. leave her alone
that stung
Judas left that feast and made the the
deal for for 30 pieces of silver so
um he was mad at Christ because Christ
exposed him but no place does it say
Christ gave up on him so Judas wasn't
predestined to be lost he was he was
Avail and I think you said this well the
same Grace the same forgiveness that was
available to everyone else including
Peter was available to him right he just
didn't take advantage of absolutely and
that is important and you know you're
mentioning Pastor something very very
clear that it is truly important to keep
in mind that us
Judas was working with Christ as he was
working with Jesus he had the chance to
be converted to really give himself to
the Lord he was never condemned he was
not condemned from the beginning he was
not like destined to die he just
rejected his choice but brought him to
that con to that decision where he said
um like you said not willing to accept
yes you know his grace I'm not willing
to accept that you know that work that
he has trying to do in my heart
I want to love money and I'm I don't
want to be told what to do in my life
yeah you know and security to the Lord
and that's how he becomes you know you
said uh predestined by his own decision
yeah you know yes yes well said yeah um
little by little we say
you know um Ellen White tells us that
when when Christ sent the Rich Young
Ruler away Judas was mad you know he got
upset he said we should that kid's got
money what are we sending him away for
we need to we need to we need to call
people like that into the ministry so we
can have money why do we have to be poor
all the time you know he wanted he
wanted the money right and slowly the
money took over his heart yeah so that
there was no room for Jesus so he was
setting himself up and even with that
betrayal which Christ predicted he could
have been forgiven he could have been
saved but he chose not to accept the
Salvation that is open to every man uh
Pastor yeah and just to finish with this
you know the the verse that Jesus used
when he
announced who was going to betray them
in the last night you know what he said
and and maybe this is where perhaps uh
Dr Fred was thinking that he was
condemned but only the only thing that
Christ said in Matthew 26 24 it says
that that the son of man God at his
written of him but one to the Man by
whom the son of man is betrayed it had
been good for that man if he had not
been born in other words that decision
that uh choice that he made Judas to
this you know reject and
betray his master
put him in that
life of perishing of condemnation
basically and yes at the end of the day
you know when the Lord will return
everyone that's rejected that light and
the love of Christ and will you know
even though they had opportunities to be
repented to transform to come to be
converted by the Lord they
they're gonna feel the same way and
they're gonna have to desire we wish we
would not be born you know like like
what Jesus said so basically he's not
cursing him because he was condemned to
be cursed he's just basically telling
him your decision is placing you right
now
in the path of destruction and you're
gonna wish you're gonna be born and
that's basically what you know well said
your decision has put you in this
channel exactly uh it's not uh
predestined that you be lost but uh any
unrepented sin is gonna result in in
loss you know if we confess we he's
faithful and just to forgive that that's
a that's an ironclad promise that is
always always true so it's a good
question and and earlier in my Ministry
I had that same thing you know somebody
had to do it why blame Judas well Judas
set himself up for it but even to the
end he could have been forgiven uh and
and should have been forgiven amen but
uh he he chose his money over you know
if you think about it and this is like
why answers get so long things come to
my mind he he he thought he was doing a
good deed I pick up 30 pieces of silver
I forced Jesus to declare his
messiahship you know
um very few of the disciples really
understood the mission of Jesus even
John the Baptist didn't understand
totally what Jesus was trying to do so
he didn't understand he he acted on his
misunderstanding and he lost his soul uh
but he could have understood and should
have understood and should have fallen
on the grace of Christ and Judas uh I
guess just took maybe you know as you
mentioned this Judas never repented
you know after he even sold you know his
master he didn't repent the Healer you
said he was thinking he reasoned he was
going to help him become a you know the
king of Israel but in reality he was uh
interested in money and that person you
know put him in this path of of
Destruction to the point when he saw
that Christ was not going to do anything
about it yes the weight of the you know
of the guilt he felt uh really was too
much to bear but he was not repented for
the sin yeah you know yeah even though
he acted and he he went and threw back
the money before the priest and all
those things you know that was not an
act of repentance no just he was afraid
of what would happen to him for turning
you know innocent blood or you know and
he's a man being killed so it's really
not repentance he experienced it was
more just the fear of the condemnation
that was already in his mind yes yes yes
all occasion by holding on to one sin so
the lesson for lesson for us uh Pastor
David is a little 11 11 at the whole
level that's right if there is sin in
your life you've got to jettison that
out of your life because it's going to
spoil your entire Christian experience
by holding on to one sin by repeating
one sin it can ruin your walk with the
Lord so as the Lord reveals sin to you
you've got to get rid of that sin so you
can can continue your walk with Jesus
amen yeah amen all right well all right
you you want to meet to read the next
question I surely do okay I'll do the
next question it's a very interesting
question I want to hear all you'd
expertise about this one it's a very
very good question comes from to us from
uh I cannot pronounce that name but uh
somebody that sent this question is is
uh really wants to understand more about
the word of God and then I pray the Lord
for that
um it says in my understanding God is
offended by sin and also his holy
presence is a consuming fire meaning
that only those who are pure in heart
are able to see God or behold his
unapproachable glory or else if Sinners
should try to look at him they will
cease to exist
then this is the question now then how
is it possible that Satan was able to
represent planet Earth in the Heavenly
meeting and approach God's presence and
talk to him in the Book of Job since we
all know that he was expelled from
Heaven because of the iniquity that was
found in him it's a good question yeah
because when you think of he should not
have come the answer is really very
simple God allowed it
um the sons of God are coming together
the planets are being represented God
allowed this to happen
um we know that that that God hates sins
but and to wherever uh sin is God is a
consuming fire so the Lord allowed this
for a purpose
um the whole job experience is is a
lesson book for the people of God uh
dealing with suffering dealing with
serving God through suffering dealing
with standing by God through something
but it is set up by a discussion between
Satan and and the Lord so it's it's
something that God allowed right for the
purpose of showing uh how someone can
withstand the assault of Satan and still
stand strong in the Lord amen and the
you know an important uh aspect or
additional aspect mentioned is the fact
that God
at the beginning of the rebellion of
Lucifer in heaven you know we can read
that in Ezekiel 28 13 and to 17 it
speaks that you know he was in the
presence of God Lucifer was in the
presence of God yet when he developed
that iniquity that was found in his life
in his heart
which had no reason there was no logical
explanation to why it is generated in
him
God himself did not destroy him by that
moment correct he allowed him that's why
it's important he allowed it why would
God not destroyed or allow his presence
to destroy and as being who was
committing sin the question the reason
is because he needed to let sin develop
you know to certain degree understand
this in the great controversy aspect you
know of Good and Evil God could not
uh destroy sin at the very beginning or
else the questions will remain forever
he had to allow because remember God in
his mercy and his grace he's a you know
and his love he does not want people to
obey him without thinking without
choosing to decide to love him and so he
had to allow that being Lucifer to hold
sin his heart and then and the Lord
worked you know Spirit prophecy tells us
specifically about those experience you
know he he he pleaded with him he
reasoned with him you know to to get
away from sin and yet he left you know
he he did not destroy him right there at
the moment so he allowed so in the Book
of Job as you mentioned as a question
you know was said he stated in the
question yes uh God will allow it
because it's part of what he would do
for a second to develop his whole
um War I guess against his character and
his law you know I think your your point
is well taken at any point in the past
seven thousand years of this controversy
God could have with justification cut
this thing off but he chose not to
remember God is putting up with sin also
at this point time until sin and sinners
are eradicated so for the sake of the
Salvation experience and experiment God
allowed that to happen you recall
um Ellen White says that
um when Satan realized that he was it
was the war was lost
um he wanted reinstatement right uh uh
so he came to Christ and asked for
reinstatement he brought his sinful
character to Christ and said I want to
get back uh but Christ said no because
your heart has not changed right I
cannot trust you back in here
um I cannot
um When sin was forming Satan himself
didn't really know the the where it was
going to lead absolutely because it was
brand new it was something that had
never existed before Christ knew where
it was going to go but Satan so they
gave him time they pleaded with him They
begged with him they allowed him uh time
but he stirred up the Angels he he
accused Christ he accused God uh he said
his heart but there was no immediate
destruction so so God is is is able to
and I've got to be careful how I say
this to countenance sin for the for the
greater good so he he's putting up with
Satan for all of these years so that no
one can say I didn't have a fair chance
no one ever told me about it
um I didn't understand this just the way
he did in heaven so that the Angels
could not say well we didn't know we
didn't have a fair chance but we didn't
understand uh uh and of course it became
Crystal Clear when Christ came and Satan
used his opportunity to destroy Christ
so it's very clear from that point on
exactly what he was about amen and uh uh
exactly where he was was leading exactly
and that's important thank you Pastor
Mary is really clear that I think that
in his Mercy just allowed that and Satan
of course had access to the heavily you
know Throne just because the Lord
allowed it to happen you know so yeah
very interesting
um the next question we have is is
coming from uh Mahesh and this is from
uh actually from England but or Great
Britain actually
Ireland my mistake I'm in Ireland it
says uh uh I am originally from India
and living in Ireland now insurance is
something which became very essential
now
life insurance health insurance serious
illness cover Insurance mortgage
insurance income protection insurance
car insurance travel insurance Etc are
some insurances that we are encouraged
to get cover for
as Christians can we take insurance
does insurance mean not having faith in
God can we take life insurance are there
some insurances we can take and some
which we must not take what is the
concept from the Bible and the spirit of
Prophecy and so this is the question
that they that Mahesh has for us yeah
thank you Mahesh for your question uh
it's good to know that we are being seen
in Ireland and that is great I look at
insurance this way
um there's a text first Timothy chapter
5 verse 8. that says if a person does
not take care of his family he's worse
than an infernal I see insurance as part
of looking out for my family if
God forbid I die
um I would want my wife my children my
family to be taken care of
um I cannot depend on anyone taking care
of them for me
I must make provision to take care of
them myself
and I see insurance as doing it I don't
see insurance as a lack of faith I mean
every day I get up and live and move and
have my being that's at the behest of
and with the blessing of God but if by
some
chance something happens to me I would
like to be sure yeah that those who are
dependent upon me are taken care of uh
and that's what I see insurance as
provider I think it's as part of my
god-given responsibility to take care
and look out for my family absolutely
Pastor he actually says or like you said
in first Timothy but also Proverbs 13 22
that you know a good man you know leave
it inheritance to his children's
children in other words even to
grandchildren you know and so if we are
planning our lives you know part of
financial responsibilities is to see how
we can provide for families in the event
of a tragedy you know and at the same
time car insurances you know you've had
an accident one maybe or I don't know if
you have an accident or not but you know
you have maybe had hit somebody or
somebody hit you and insurance prevents
you from having to you know uh put out
all that money from your pocket but yes
you know it's is it's one of the ways
that the system is made is not a perfect
system obviously it's not like you know
but it works if you are able to now if
you are not a able to pay bills you know
or provide for your family for having
all these insurances I think you have to
yeah you need to reevaluate yeah I know
that so but now the you know the the
aspect of trust in the Lord it of course
is important I mean we're not saying
that you know we need to trust in
insurances to cover for things you know
if in the case of
you know somebody that can have a good
healthy lifestyle you know you might not
have to necessarily
worry so much in in getting coverages of
every type of illness you know there is
yes if that's if you're following dollar
but you know if you are you know perhaps
have a condition or some sort of you
know situation in medical the needs a
medical attention it's probably is wise
you have that you know it's it's very
important that we you know look and use
all the elements that we have in our
disposal to make decisions that are
sound that won't be a strained to the
family to you know to the loved ones or
to the church even well said what's that
you know in most countries you cannot
even operate a vehicle without auto
insurance you have to have it that's not
optional you have to have it I have you
know I've had open heart surgery I've
had six bypasses I've had prostate
cancers another surgery I've had 13 eye
operations
I could not be here today unless I had
insurance
we would not be
not been test they put some injection
some dye when they were doing my open
heart one test fifty seven thousand
dollars for for one test wow um and my
open heart surgery
I think that was 297 000 something like
that I don't have that kind of money so
if I didn't have insurance uh like I
said we wouldn't be having this
conversation so there are certain
insurances that are necessary you you
need to have them uh and it is not it is
not unwise to get them in fact I think
it helps you provide for your family
um and so
um I would not feel bad about getting
insurance I think that's part of taking
care of yourself and taking care of your
family and I think that is biblically
defensible and the text that uh Pastor
David gave uh and and the one in first
Timothy I think are are very very
applicable
Pastor our time has fast slipped into
eternity and this always happens yes
I've heard people say my sister always
says you know you need to have that
program for an hour uh because rarely do
we finish our questions I think we got
to two three I think three or three okay
yeah we did get to three uh and there
was a long one that we didn't get to
we'll take a look at next time again God
bless you we'll see you again real soon
God bless stay well
foreign
[Music]